the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright we're going to how about hosting
I'm going to go through rules quickly
guidelines just the same as we did
before then I'm going to read a short
section of one of your scripts you're
going to critique my hosting and then
we'll do the same thing for some of you
we again we won't talk to we won't do
everyone this we covered already don't
read it tell it this is what Ira Glass
the Ira Glass video before from before
this is a subtle point you can start off
by imitating someone else's hosting
style but you'll invariably just get
caught as like that's the only thing
that you can do and it's since it's not
your own personality it's just sort of
weird and unnatural and doesn't work I
did this when I was first starting out
it did not end well these are my words
of wisdom to you and no more needs to be
said about that this is a really hard
one so there's this device called the
it's called a like interview something I
don't know that there's a famous
director who basically has a silvered
mirror that he puts in front of the
camera so that and there's an image
below it's like a teleprompter except
instead of text you see a person's face
you see the interviewers face so the
interviewee is looking straight into the
camera lens but that person is actually
seeing the face of the person who's
interviewing so who's seen the movie the
fog of war yeah no one else okay you
should watch it it's really interesting
it's it's basically it's a documentary
it's an interview movie and rich not not
Richard Nixon the Secretary of War for
the Vietnam War was McNamara so he was
interviewed on on that movie using this
technique and it's a really interesting
technique but the point is when you look
into the camera we don't have a fancy
device like that unfortunately but when
you look into a camera see a person's
face preferably someone that you know
whether it's like a friend husband wife
son daughter whatever it is pick someone
and see their face on camera that is the
quickest and easiest way to make your
hosting
more natural without really thinking
about it and that's very hard to do
because you're thinking of your script
you're thinking of 18,000 other things
but that's the most important rule
usually the camera tones you down so if
you are talking like you would normally
talk you will kind of seemed like this
on camera it just it just tones you down
and slows you down and the lower is your
energy level unless it's right in your
face then it then it's different but
usually it's not right in your face so
you need to compensate by I really
hesitate to say like up your energy
level because when people say that the
initial reaction is to be like and then
you need to talk like this because
that's how you know and like that just
doesn't work either so you want to be a
more energetic version of your natural
self so I think of like if you were just
really excited about something how would
you actually be that's how you should be
on camera and just like
metrics higher energy doesn't need
higher pitch that's like the biggest
thing that happens in the sailing now
it's more energy then people talk with a
high end toward like this and that's
lacking wanna do 10 yeah okay so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
read this and you all are going to
critique my hosting style and I'm going
to read it as if I'm going to deliver it
sorry as if like oh wait no this is much
of this as a quote so let me do
something else I'll do this I'm going to
deliver this as though like it's not my
job okay ready here we go why do some
people handle cold better than others
why is it that some are so fearful of
the cold that they'd rather die than be
caught outside with all the winter gear
on masks and all while others can wear
one layer for a morning jog what makes
all the difference okay critique what
was wrong with that yeah I feel like two
more see we restrained by the fact
you're looking at somebody else's work
okay that is true so if I was if I was
reading something that I would that I
have written myself I'd probably do a
better job but in this case I you will
be reading your own work so that won't
be quite the same yeah so they just how
you've read it it seemed like you're
asking question but it's not really like
there's no life oh yeah I've never
thought that it's like why some people
handle cold any others but it may be
cheese like if it we wondered why some
people Concetta I'm of its structure
that sentence it just tasted it so there
is and this is part of the exercises i'm
reading it word for word so let's assume
that i can't change the wording i mean
in real life you can but what could i do
just with intonation of my voice or what
else may be slow down a little bit okay
yeah and really hit that question okay
you were gonna you right here no you had
your hand up okay the donation we ask
the question you probably want to
breathe it
if you were to ask a very much because
they have a couple of questions here so
i guess you can pick the one that you
really want them to think and give them
pause so get them to think before which
may be cool that's a good point that you
can create suspension in your tone of
voice but a lot of people make the
mistake of assuming that every question
has to end with up tomm right a powerful
question can be posed with the tone
anything why do some people handle cold
better than others right that is still a
strong question even though I didn't say
why do some people handle the cold
better than others right like that
actually is well you didn't end up word
on either one of those write the ending
up word is like why do some people
handle cold better than others like
that's the traditional way that people
ask question but but i agree with you
like the way that i read it all the
questions were flat all had the same
intonation what i really want to do is
very so something like why do some
people handle cold better than others
why is it that some are so fearful of
the cold they'd rather die than be
caught outside with alt without all the
winter gear on all the masks and all
that stuff where other people can just
wear one layer for a morning jog what's
the difference right so each question i
asked there in a totally different way
what else
so a big piece of advice that we give to
students is to think about the words
that you're saying which is also the
hardest thing to do when you're trying
to remember everything that you're
saying or give a camera in front of you
but that's also why we often see the
script away from the student is it's
easy to get caught up in oh [ __ ] I have
to remember all the words and I'm very
very guilty of this as well so I totally
understand how hard it is to do but when
you are asking the question generally
why do some people get called while
other people don't like the way I said
that was very different than why do some
people handle cold better than others
right when I'm actually thinking about
the words that I'm saying which is a
very obvious suggestion to make but
again very hard to implement yourself
the intonation and the delivery becomes
a lot more natural and genuine
yeah that's that's another rule like you
know when you look into the camera see
someone's face that's something that is
something that you can do that doesn't
mean it requires some preparation but it
doesn't require thought while you're
actually doing it so when you look in
the camera see someone's face and
actually think about the words that
you're that you're saying is helpful to
you want to avoid monotony but just in
the intonation so you don't want to say
why do some people handle cold better
than the others why is it that some our
so fearful right that's monotonous and
tone but it's also monotonous in rhythm
right so when george said it the second
time he rushed through some of the the
words in the middle that weren't a list
which is very natural when we're like
this morning i are going to work and I
have to do this and I do this is you
rush through things that you list
whereas if you're just reading like you
would read you say it with the same
rhythmic pacing make the pauses where
the punctuation is you sound very even
with the way you break up your words and
that's super unnatural that's why it
sounds robotic right so when you mix up
not only the intonation but also the
speed at which you're delivering some of
the words so
and then you can do it again and made me
pay attention to how he does it that's
kind of also why it feels a lot more
natural so I'm going to do it again this
time completely different and get your
critique as well why do some people
handle cold better than others why is it
that some are so fearful of the cold
that they would rather die than be
caught outside without all the winter
gear on masks and all while others can
wear one layer for a morning jog what's
the difference was that better or worse
than the first time I did it sounds like
a TED video oh man then I'm not making
very good Ted videos ok why what was
inauthentic about that yeah so normally
when we say to someone like up your
energy or when anyone says that that's
what comes out is you get this like
weird like I have to really try to be
excited about this because I don't
really know what I'm reading but I'm
going to just emphasize random words and
say them louder and that makes it
exciting no it doesn't make it you know
like that that's and that and especially
if you mix that in with like a bit of
news caster II then you're just dead in
the water because you know you hit you
end up with like the most unwatchable
video ever and you sound like you're
trying to talk
the final
ok now I'm going to read it again and
this is going to be a bit more subtle
here we go why do some people handle
cold better than others why is it that
some are so fearful of the cold that
they'd rather die than be caught outside
without all the winter gear on masks and
all while others can wear one layer and
be fine what makes the difference what
does that sound like to you definitely
sounds more natural any critique of it
Wow
like and I talking to
it's like yeah I mean why is it that
then and i'm at right there is it is
very natural but there is a lack of like
wonder about that this is something this
is a topic that I sort of taking for
granted you know and I've like I'm sort
of expect that you'll take it for
granted too so you you do take it for
granted all right I sort of run out of
different ways to do that so let's have
you guys try who did not have their
script analyzed come on up
so take my hot seat there and give us
Arita why do some people handle cold
better than others why is it that some
are so fearful of the cold that they'd
rather die than be caught outside
without all the winter gear on masks and
all while others can wear one layer for
a morning jog what makes all the
difference differently do it differently
by the way sorry those of you that will
do production with me and Elizabeth that
is the phrase that you will hear most
throughout the week is one more time go
ahead why do some people handle cold
better than others why is it that some
people are so fearful of the cold though
they'd rather die than be caught outside
without all the winter gear on masks and
all while others can wear one layer for
a morning jog what makes all the
difference do you have the first
sentence memorized deliver it without
looking at the script why do some people
handle the cold better than others now
look at Elizabeth and just ask her that
question why do some people handle cold
better than others now like don't don't
don't have the line in your head just
ask her why do some people handle the
cold weather in the notice now ask me as
if I were Eric lender
I've never seen him why do some people
handle a cold better than others what
was missing closer okay i'm i'm a
professor and you're on my office hours
and I've given you the pset question
relating to hyperthermia why do some
people handle look hold better than
others now like ask the question in your
own words like don't use the words that
are that are written on the script
ask Elizabeth why are some people so
immune to the cold so do people see how
hard this is this is really not easy
right thanks you're good come on back
all right who's next your turn
same paragraph
why do some people handle cold better
than others why is it that some are so
fearful the cold that they'd rather die
than be caught outside with all the
winter gear on masks and all while
others can wear one layer of a morning
jog what makes all the difference why do
some people handle the cold better than
others why is it that some is so fearful
the call that they'd rather die than be
caught outside with all the winter gear
on masks and all while others can wear
one layer for a morning jog what makes
all the difference I do the first line
not reading I hobo memory John don't
don't worry about the words everyone
I guess just
when I'm digital video about dealing
with the cold weather or okay I have a
wire some people better at dealing cold
than others okay you can sit down so um
anyone else want to go any well son to
give it a shot yeah come on up
same paragraph why do some people handle
cold better than others why is it that
some people are so fearful of the call
that they'd rather die than be caught
outside with all the winter gear on mass
and all while others can wear one there
in the morning John what makes all the
difference why do some people handle
cold better than others why is it that
some are so fearful of the code that
they'd rather die then we caught outside
with all the winter gear on masks and
all while others can wear one layer in
the morning job what makes all the
difference great thanks what time is it
to have time ok what did you guys notice
about all of all of those all three
deliveries
were they different or similar
both the personalities came through okay
but it sounds like there's a button but
they had a really hard time doing
something different from what they did
the first time
I'm not I don't know why this is I don't
have any like cognitive theory as to
like why it's so hard to do something so
differently sorry why it's hard to read
when you have the same words in front of
you why it's very difficult to read them
in different ways but it just this just
happens with everyone and like what
especially if you've written the script
yourself you know you know the words so
well you've looked at it a million times
when it comes time to actually be on
camera and perform that script and we
say like okay well that was a great but
do it a different way you're like well I
wrote it this one way why should I do it
a different way maybe that's what your
brain is thinking and so you don't know
how just don't know how to do it a
different way let's try something a
little weird and creative what you Leo
right do the first line but try and do
it as different from your first reading
as you possibly can and I mean if you
want to exaggerate not like don't think
of this as I'm hosting a line just think
of it as like I'm going to say these
words in the most different way I can
think of yeah like why do some people
handle cold better
so valley girl okay good that was very
different than your first delivery great
remind me of your name again Joshua go
ahead do the first line totally
different than the way you did it and
not valley girl either we put some yeah
hey what do people sometimes handle cold
better than others okay that was an
accent so great very different mommy of
your name again Nathan your turn why
some people handle cold better than
office Yulia yellow the line why do some
people handle cold better than others
okay now close your eyes and just say it
ask the question why do some people
handle cold better than others okay that
was your best delivery I don't know why
like sometimes getting people to step
way outside their comfort zone and do a
line in a totally ridiculous way that
you would never actually use resets
something in your mental circuitry I
have no explanation for why this works
but like you get out of your normal and
you then you just you just sort of do it
the way that you would normally do it if
you were talking to someone that's a
technique that will also use when when
you were in production will be like okay
you know actually we might even say like
do this line as a valley girl do it with
an accent yell it out loud you know do
it like a robot why do some people
handle cold better than others and then
like do it in your normal why do some
people handle cold better than others I
mean that was different than how I've
done it every single time what other
hosting tech mean this is just one of
those things that practice you need to
practice and you should do it like I was
saying earlier with an audio recorder
you have them doing vlogs right it might
be good to change one of those
assignments into an audio vlog versa
socially so for your daily reflection
I no sirree did a video just to make
sure that you guys but you don't have to
do text reflections you can do an audio
recording if you want you can do a video
blog if you want and I think that's a
great opportunity to practice some of
this stuff like your reflection last
night is really good it was really
authentic you weren't trying to host but
I thought you did a pretty good job on
camera and it was very different from
your pitch right I got would suggest
that you go back and watch yourself on
both your pitch and on your blog last
night and you'll see a pretty surprising
difference and it happens to all of us
when you listen to like that's the other
part of this is that once you do your
you know vlog reflection or whatever or
audio blogger murder listen to it and
see what you sound like do one where
you're just talking off the cuff you
know you're like today was great we had
this guy was you know he was terrible
but he had some good points whatever
whatever and then do one where you
actually read you could read even this
same paragraph if you want or pick
something that you've written and listen
to the difference I think it's only by
sort of really listening to yourself
that you will learn to do this yeah you
ever try to have people do
how I could practice dry runs you know
yes yeah we do that all the time it um I
mean will say oh this is a rehearsal
we're not rolling but go ahead and you
know go ahead and deliver the line
anyway sometimes it works it usually
doesn't because you've still got the
camera there yeah it's it's still yeah
and the other thing is even though we
want you to sound as natural as possible
when it comes to the day of shooting the
more you practice your lines it just
takes that one more confounding variable
that will stress you out during the day
of shoot that the students you can
really tell if they rehearse their lines
even if we end up changing a lot of the
wording they're just much more
comfortable because they're not worrying
about remembering things they actually
are thinking about the words that
they're saying
for tonight's assignment it will just be
to recreate your episode pitch and you
can I would suggest that you read raft
your script we are going to do a table
read next Monday and there's no official
assignment for another draft of a script
until then if you want feedback on any
material that would be right which I
would recommend and I'm happy to give
feedback George ship on the world or it
is happy then get his emails also on the
syllabus we're all happy to give
feedback that will have additional
office hours today tomorrow friday so
there's lots of opportunity for a
feedback before the table read but just
so you guys know for tonight it's just a
reaping I'm gonna gia for your episode
that's all the material that i had does
anyone have any questions in the two
minutes remaining and I'm going to stick
around so if you guys want to chat with
me individually that's fine too you just
yeah them to the moat to the to the most
extent that you can be yourself yeah and
I mean there are exceptions to every
single roll I know about when I hope
star very different them I am in real
life not really yeah yeah very recently
said that I my hosting persona was alive
and then you were expecting no just
messing me but um for the most part be
yourself like and we mean that very
literally right I don't know if you guys
noticed but that time you asked that
question at the very end like it was it
was how you would say it and it
so so less like a pitch to like get
people tip it just kind of explain what
your dinner yeah as I have a pitch kind
of you know just say on it it's kind of
like excited when you think of pets you
think of like shark tank and you think I
have 30 seconds to get someone to buy
buy buy into my idea so I'm just going
to be as loud and exaggerated as
possible so please don't mistake pitch
for that keep it under a minute and a
half a lot of your videos is really five
and a half minutes that's like longer
than your entire absence is going to be
keep it under a minute and a half I
really I not just has a challenge but
that'll really help structure the way
you deliver and this should be the point
of your video
so maybe not think about it as a pitch
as it is a point like a thesis think of
it as explaining your video to someone
else
this is not the actual stuff people
it's like a trailer remember Paul right
that yeah remember when Paul was doing
his shoe box thing it's that yes you can
just mine yeah we get we got we got
about a dollar fifty okay thanks guys
hey we'll stick around for a while you
guys have question